I'm a frequent camper I like to drive
around and camp wherever I can and sure
we like to have some cold beers in the
morning but sometimes you just don't
want to have a cold beer while you're
camping so I just reached for my Coleman
blender here and it's 60 bucks you can't
lose you can make the margarita instead
just throw some ice in this bad boy
great tequila of choice throw it in no
need to measure because that would just
waste the dish that you would have to
clean later throw some of this in there
and it's all good and while I'm waiting
for this to blend you got to have a tidy
ship here while you're out on the road
so I reach for my 70 dollar vacuum from
Black & Decker it's on the go it's easy
to use just plug it in with one of these
in a cigarette lighter or in various
outlets that you may have in your
vehicle
and now it's time for my drink
I love camping